sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
hier im Saal des monami und auch liebe
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen an den
Bildschirmen das ganze wird live
gestreamt und auch das werden Sie noch
nicht wissen der Saal unter uns ist auch
gut gefüllt weil die Räume sind begrenzt
und wir sehen das bei dieser Thematik
natürlich ein Iris ein großes Interesse
ist das ist auch gut so ich begrüße sie
im Namen der Volkshochschule Weimar
herzlich zum heutigen Podiumsgespräch
putinskrieg der russische Überfall und
seine Folgen so eine Veranstaltung da
bin ich mir sicher mit ihnen einer
Meinung zu sein die wir lieber nicht
hätten aber ein Jahr Krieg in der
Ukraine fordert uns viel ab auch hier in
Deutschland auch hier in Weimar
und deswegen haben wir als
Volkshochschule auch diese Veranstaltung
ins Leben gerufen viele Flüchtlinge sind
in den letzten Jahr zu uns gekommen nach
Deutschland nach Weimar auch sehr vieler
die VHS hat sehr frühzeitig begonnen für
vor allem Kinder und Jugendliche mit dem
Bundesprogramm Talent Campus für diese
Kinder zu sorgen mit Angeboten zum
Sprache lernen zum gesellschaftlichen
Kontakte knüpfen die Kultur natürlich
auch ein Stück weit und das gleiche
machen wir bis heute so es nötig ist
auch für Erwachsene und auch die Stadt
Weimar war kurz nach Kriegsbeginn aktiv
ein Hilfstransport startete relativ
schnell in Richtung Ukraine bis Samos
der Partnerstadt in Polen kurz vor der
Grenze dort und Peter kleine den ich
hier begrüßen möchte der
Oberbürgermeister dieser Stadt war mit
dabei kleine welche Eindrücke haben sie
vor einem Jahr mit zurückgebracht aus
der Region
ja von mir ein wunderschönen guten Abend
die Eindrücke sind sehr surreal gewesen
wir hatten relativ schnell auch
ein Hilfstransport zusammenstellen
können wir hatten
nachgefragt worden Medikamente vor allen
Dingen es wurde nachgefragt auch
Lebensmittel und wir haben dann
letztlich mittlerweile drei
Hilfstransporte schon nach Samos das ist
die Partnerstadt von der Stadt Weimar
gebracht es haben auch wiederum ist
ungefähr 50 km von der ukrainischen
Grenze entfernt und die samarsche haben
wiederum eine Partnerstadt in der
Ukraine die heißt in der Nähe von von
ähm und das ist auch etwa noch mal von
der Grenze Nummer 50 km entfernt also
relativ nah und ähm wir haben dann
zusammen diese hilfs-transporte dann
auch in die Ukraine gebracht und wenn
man sich vorstellt man kommt von dem
Land wo alles funktioniert Deutschland
und dann ist man in der Ukraine wo man
mit mit vielen Militärposten begrüßt
wird
hat man schon den ganzen mulmiges Gefühl
und gleichzeitig haben ja so viel
Dankbarkeit empfunden dass wir relativ
schnell hilfs-transporte
zusammengestellt haben
dass da auch mittlerweile Freundschaften
entstanden sind
das Schlimmste was was man im Grunde
erleben musste sind die vielen Menschen
die auf der Flucht waren und dann an der
polnischen Grenze wie so ein wie so eine
Reihe Ameisen dann auch standen und
meistens Frauen und Kinder die ihre
Männer teilweise verabschiedet haben und
das das hat richtig geschmerzt und
deswegen sind die Dinge die wir quasi
als Belastung empfinden eine sehr sehr
relativ das ist auch das Stichwort der
Zeit hat Weimar stand letzte Woche 830
Menschen aus der Ukraine aufgenommen
darunter auch 250 schulpflichtige Kinder
wie ist der Stand in Weimar wir sind
diese Flüchtlinge untergebracht wie ist
da der Stand im Augenblick auch für die
nahe Zukunft
ja also das Thema Unterbringung das ist
glaube ich ein Thema was was in ganz
Deutschland ein Problem ist oder wir
haben es geschafft bislang wirklich
Turnhallen eben zu vermeiden wir haben
letztlich aufgrund der enormen
Solidarität die es hier in Weimar von
Anfang an gab es haben sich so viele
Privatpersonen auch bereit erklärt auch
Wohnraum zur Verfügung zu stellen das
sind auch heute noch Menschen in
Privatwohnungen untergebracht wir haben
natürlich kleiner Unterkünfte aktiviert
jetzt ganz ganz neu ein ehemaliger
Kindergarten den wir nicht mehr brauchen
der ist jetzt wird aktiviert der wird
Anfang März bezogen und dort hatten wir
auch Anwohnerversammlung gemacht und
dort ist wenn man den Menschen erklärt
ist da auch ein Verständnis da und auch
die die ganze Frage der
Solidarität wir haben als Stadt weil man
in Spendenaufruf gemacht und über
200.000 Euro an Spendenmitteln sind
zusammengekommen und das ist für eine
Stadt die Weimar enorm enorm viel und
auf diese Solidarität die auch teilweise
auch Sonntag das immer wieder gezeigt
wird durch durch sag mal Kundgebung die
mittlerweile 55 mal erhaltenreiches hier
im Publikum gemacht werden einfach um
auf die Situation aufmerksam zu machen
und diesen Zusammenhalt den es hier gibt
auch weiterhin zu stärken und das macht
einen dann wirklich stolz dann in so
einer Stadt aufzubauen das ist richtig
vielen Dank Peter kleine das ist ein
kleiner Auszug jetzt gewesen aus Weimar
dass wir den vielen vielen Städten und
Kommunen in Deutschland ähnlich sein
aber sie sind natürlich jetzt hier um ja
große Politik von Menschen zu hören die
in den Krisengebieten waren sind die
sich auskennen ein Stück weit bislang
tausende Menschen in der Ukraine sind
gestorben Soldaten Soldatinnen
Zivilisten auch also es ist eine
Situation die eigentlich nicht tragbar
ist ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht ein
politischer Ende ist nicht in Sicht wie
es dort werden kann wir wissen es
einfach nicht wir hoffen uns natürlich
heute Abend von diesem Museum keine
Antworten die kann man nicht geben aber
vielleicht doch einige Impulse mit der
Stand ist wie die Entwicklung sein
könnte und das denke ich mir ist
Koalition des heutigen Abends möchte
aber bevor ich das Wort ans Podium gebe
noch das muss man einfach machen wenn
die Volkshochschule weimar ist eine
kleine und finanziell auch nicht so
wahnsinnig ausgestattet genügend passend
halt wir haben natürlich diese
Veranstaltung nur mit Förderern auch
durchführen können über das
bundesfamilienminister fördert uns
unterstützt und das Bildungsminister
Ministerium in Erfurt in Thüringen
unterstützt und denkt und über dieses
Landesprogramm werden wir mit
unterstützt die Stiftung Buchenwald
Mittelbau Dora ist mit dabei und vor
allem auch das werden sie gesehen haben
der MDR zum ersten Mal in der
Größenordnung für uns halt überträgt
diese Veranstaltung auch im Livestream
im Augenblick Halt und das ist natürlich
für uns ganz wichtig und sehr schön dass
wir herauskommen und dazu Klammer auf
möchte ich bitten das ist die übliche
dass sie ihre Handys gerne nach der
Veranstaltung wieder anschalten sollten
das zerstört einfach die Übertragungen
wo die mir gesagt also bitte das machen
das was von mir aus vielen Dank ich
begrüße das Podium und übergebe jetzt
gerne an Thomas Roth den Moderator des
heutigen Abend vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ja guten Abend Herren sie warten auf
Thomas Roth auf das Podium wir haben
leider von Seiten des MDR ein kleines
technisches Problem der Ton wird im
Livestream nicht übertragen und sie
wissen dass viele natürlich genauso wie
Sie interessiert sind an dem Monitoren
dass sie diese Veranstaltung die
Podiumsdiskussion mitbekommen die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind dabei und
versuchen natürlich dieses Manko
aufzuheben ich hoffe Sie haben ein wenig
Verständnis und dass wir in wenigen
Minuten weitermachen können mit der
Bitte auch um Verständnis von Podium
vielen Dank
das heißt wir machen jetzt noch eine
kleine Pause okay
dann sage ich aber das was nicht
gesendet werden muss ich freue mich dass
ich heute abend bei ihnen im Weimar sein
kann
und ich glaube das gilt für uns alle was
wir im Laufe unseres Gesprächs
vielleicht auch noch deutlich machen für
mich
das muss ja alles nicht gesendet werden
ich fülle jetzt so ein bisschen Zeit
aber
rede hoffentlich nicht komplett in
Unsinn ich bin gerne in Weimar ich bin
auch nicht zum ersten Mal in Weimar
eine wirklich für mich beeindruckende
Stadt und
ich willkommen beide aus
Baden-Württemberg was der Schüler uns
bedeutet wissen wir ja es gibt es gibt
einen einen relativ
unintelligenten Spruch bei mir ich komme
aus Schwaben der der geht so der
Schiller und der Hegel der Schilling und
da
muss nicht gesendet werden aber mir ist
auf unseren Schilder sind wir doch
glaube ich nach wie vor Stolz und Goethe
ist dann muss ich nichts zu sagen also
bin wirklich gerne hier
habe auch natürlich das was etwa zehn
Kilometer von uns hier entfernt sich
abgespielt hat im Buchenwald erlebt und
und kenne das ganz gut aus einer ganzen
Reihe von Gründen insofern denke ich ist
Weimar so die sozusagen ein eine
deutsche Welt in der gewissen Weise
die das ganze Drama aber auch große
Höhepunkte
finde ich verkörpert und das erlebe ich
jedes Mal wenn ich nach Weimar komme und
es berührt mich auch außerordentlich
eben weil es so viele so viele
Schwingungen hat und wenn ich jetzt höre
was gerade gesagt worden ist dass die
Weimarer auch nur so spendenfreudig sind
für die Ukraine umso besser ihr seid
toll das finde ich schon mal gut so
könnte ruhig platzen aber für euch
[Applaus]
zum ersten Mal hier in Weimar mit
Sicherheit nicht da oh Gott aber was ist
ihr Eindruck vom von dem schönen
Städtchen
[Gelächter]
eine ganz besondere Stadt sie ist ja
nicht nur
die Stadt von Goethe und Schiller
sondern wir hatten ja meine Weimarer
Republik und der Weimarer Verfassung
und ich fand übrigens
ganz gut
dass bei der entsprechenden
Jubiläumsveranstaltung der
Bundespräsident
einmal zu Recht gerückt hat die Weimarer
Verfassung ist nicht ein Hitler schuld
die Weimarer Verfassung waren in Ordnung
das war nicht das Problem war eine gute
Verfassung
wenn man ja so ein bisschen so tut als
wäre die Weimarer Verfassung irgendwie
gescheitert die Weimarer Verfassung ist
nicht gescheitert solche demokratisch
gescheitert aber da waren daran waren
die Weimarer jedenfalls nicht mehr
Schuld als alle anderen
mehr und die anderen weniger
und die Lehre die wir heute übrigens
daraus ziehen können ist eine Demokratie
ohne Demokraten
hat auch die dauercamp bestand und
deswegen ist es die allerwichtigste
Lehre die wir daraus für heute für uns
Zielen müssen das hilft der Ukraine noch
nicht und es hilft uns noch nicht gegen
Putin aber für die Stabilität unserer
Demokratie und die Demokratie ist ja
wenn ich das richtig sehe überall in der
westlichen Welt
in der Krise ziemlichen vielen Krisen
gehört für mich zu den großen Sorgen die
ich habe neben all den anderen
Krisen aber sie hängt ein bisschen daran
dass wir
uns zu wenig für unsere Demokratie
engagieren
und der frühere Bundeskanzler hat auf
seine alten Tage
[Gelächter]
der hat ja immer davon gesprochen
und als ich gelesen habe
dass bei der Wiederholungswahl in Berlin
die haben ja gerade nochmal gewählt
da haben sie den Wahlhelfern
260 Euro bezahlt
und es hat offenbar kaum jemand
aufgeregt mich hat es aufgeregt weil
wenn wir für die Grundpflichten jedes
Staatsbürgers nämlich bei der Wahl
notfalls zu helfen dass man die Wahl
durchführen kann die Leute auch schon
bezahlen müssen brauchen uns nicht zu
wundern wenn die hinterher Glauben der
Staat kann alles bezahlen
und ja Geld ist ja eh unbegrenzt aber
hoffe ich dass der Ton kommt
der Ton ist da
[Applaus]
schönen guten Abend meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich freue mich dass ich
sie hier in Weimar begrüßen darf das
natürlich ein Ort muss ich ähnlich sagen
aber es bedeutet mir selbst persönlich
immer noch das ein oder andere an dem
die deutsche Klassik zu Hause ist aber
eben auch die deutsche Demokratie dafür
hat die Stadt Weimar eine enorm große
Bedeutung und im übrigen
liegt es ja gerade mal drei Jahrzehnte
zurück dass wir uns hier ohne weiteres
das irgendjemand interveniert treffen
können dürfen und reden was wir für
richtig halten das ist noch nicht so
furchtbar lange her auch in Weimar das
ist so war ich gehör nur zu der
Generation die das erstens erinnert und
zweitens auch sehr dankbar dafür ist
dass wir heute hier genau so wie wir
zusammen sind auch zusammen sein können
das sind ernste Zeiten sehr ernste
Zeiten sogar mit dem größten Landkrieg
in Europa seit 1945 das sind 90
Flugminuten von hier wer von Berlin
schon nach Kiew geflogen Katrin
Eugendorf wird gleich davon erzählt ich
habe das auch schon gemacht das sind 19
Minuten das ist man hat das Gefühl es
ist nebenan und es ist kein Gefühl es
ist nebenan deshalb befassen wir uns
unter anderem damit hoffentlich tausende
Menschen in der Ukraine sind im
russischen Raketen Hagel umgekommen
Millionen Ukraine etwa 8 Millionen sind
innerhalb und außerhalb ihres Landes was
für eine Zahl auf der Flucht und
unterwegs zum Teil ohne Perspektive das
ist ein Angriffskrieg der Europa aber
eben auch die Welt das kann man sicher
ohne Übertreibung so sagen in eine Krise
geführt hat wie groß sie werden wird
wissen wir noch nicht wir wissen aber
das ist eine ist
und warum gibt es diesen Krieg dann
dennoch wenn er so unsinnig ist und so
zerstörerisch und nur Menschen Leben
vernichtet was treibt Putin in diese
sinnlose Zerstörung die wir berichtet
bekommen und insofern dann miterleben
und warum ist er wie er selbst sagt in
einem Krieg gegen den Westen warum ist
das so
das wollen wir in den nächsten 90
Minuten besprechen wenn Sie Fragen haben
dann reichen Sie die bitte
weiter an Herrn Finke der sie einsammelt
und am Schluss gegen Ende unserer
Gesprächsrunde dann auch einbringt und
dann wollen wir natürlich auch sehr
gerne darauf eingehen
ja jetzt darf ich die Gäste hier
begrüßen und die Damen werden wir das
Nachsehen ich begrüße zuerst dr wolfgang
Schäuble ich habe schon gesagt an so
einem historischen Ort für die deutsche
Demokratie das ist wahr und ich bin
besonders froh dass wir Ihnen heute
Abend zu Gast haben denn sie wissen dass
ich ja 50 Jahre Abgeordneter im
Deutschen Bundestag und Parlamentsarbeit
die nicht immer einfach ist ich habe sie
beobachten dürfen eine ganze Reihe von
Jahren man kann sich manches einfach und
leichter vorstellen das ist eine Menge
Holz und hat für die Demokratie wie ich
glaube eine Menge gebracht ist der
dienstälteste
Abgeordnete überhaupt und ich habe in
der Vorbereitung gelesen überhaupt in
der deutschen Parlamentsgeschichte die
beginnt ja wie sie sich nicht erinnern
aber wissen im Mai 1848 in Frankfurt bei
dem berühmten Frankfurter Kirche es hat
niemanden gegeben der länger in einem
Parlament an einem deutschen Parlament
an den Deutschen Demokratischen als Herr
Schäuble
herzlich willkommen
ich will gar nicht ihre Ämter alle da
etwas lange zu reden aufzählen Minister
Finanzminister war drunter aber
natürlich auch und insbesondere der
Präsident des Deutschen Bundestages das
ist nach herrschender Staatspraxis ist
zweithöchsteamt in diesem Staat lieber
Schäuble wenn jemand der so viel
politische Erfahrung
mitbringt wie sie und da sind eine Menge
nicht kleine Krisen dabei gewesen das
muss man ja so sagen hätten sie sich war
das in ihrer Vorstellungswelt vorhanden
dass wir es in Europa noch einmal mit
einem derartigen Landkrieg einem
Angriffskrieg dieser Größenordnung zu
tun haben würden schon gar mit Russland
war das irgendwo bei ihnen präsent
naja seit
der Wende in Deutschland
Europa im Ende des Ost-
um mich noch an den 17 Juni 53 zu
erinnern
und ich habe eine ganz gute Erinnerung
noch an 56 Ungarn
und natürlich wie sie alle wenn sie
älter sind dann 68 mit dem Prager
fröhlich
und ich habe 89 beim Fall der Mauer
natürlich haben wir Tränen der Freude
vergossen
aber ich habe in der Nacht auch gedacht
hoffentlich geht's diesmal gut
denn wir hatten ja eigentlich gelernt
dass das Verändern von Grenzen nicht
mehr geht
weil es zur Krieg führt und jetzt ist es
anders geworden dann konnten wir sonst
nicht mehr vorstellen
und dass wir jetzt einen nein das konnte
ich nicht vorstellen
aber wir hätten es
wir hätten uns vorstellen können müssen
vieles falsch gemacht und oder nicht
hören wollen nicht verstehen wollen aber
das können andere besser sagen ich kann
nur sagen diejenigen
die jetzt so tun als hätten sie das
alles schon vorher genau gewusst
ich habe sie damals nicht gehört oder
jedenfalls nicht so richtig vernommen
und dabei weiß ich man hätte es
eigentlich wissen können das werden wir
besprechen das ist ja gar nicht so ganz
unstrittig wer ab wann hätte was was
wissen können das ist Teil unseres
Themas aber ich begrüße jetzt von außen
nämlich von Münster zugeschaltet Marina
weißband schönen guten Abend nach
Münster
schönen guten Abend
das ist schön dass Sie dabei sind Marina
weiß man zwei drei kleine Fakten dazu
ist ein Jahr nach der atomaren
Katastrophe in Tschernobyl in der Nähe
von Kiew geboren Mitte der 90er Jahre
mit den Eltern dann nach Deutschland
gekommen und hat hier studiert ist
Autoren Publizistin und bei den Grünen
engagiert aber verweist man sie sind
soweit ich weiß nach wie vor eng
verbunden mit der Ukraine
ja ich bin ich war jedes Jahr dort ich
habe Familie dort meine halbe Familie
mütterlicherseits ist noch komplett da
und sie kriegen sozusagen täglich oder
mehr oder weniger täglich mit was dort
geschieht
natürlich ich verfolge das seit 2013
ich war auf dem Maidan als er angefangen
hat ich musste viel Frikadellen für die
Leute backen und seitdem versuche ich
ein bisschen mit laienhaft an ein
deutsches Publikum zu vermitteln worum
es damals dort ging ich habe auch nach
2014/2015 versucht zu erklären warum wir
nicht aufhören dürfen das zu beachten zu
beachten warum wir nicht dürfen
diese Geschichte gibt mir deswegen so
nah weil tatsächlich die Stimmen die
damals laut waren nicht vernommen wurden
wieder
sie haben im im Deutschen Bundestag am
Holocaust Gedenkmal gegen den Tag wie
ich fand sehr bewegende Rede gehalten da
haben sie auch ihre persönliche
Geschichte und auch über jüdisches Leben
in Deutschland auch dass ihre gesprochen
das fand ich wirklich hat auch glaube
ich die Abgeordneten im Deutschen
Bundestag sehr beeindruckt und das
Publikum insgesamt nun hat der der
ehemalige oberrabine von Moskau
Menschen jüdischen Glaubens aufgefordert
Russland angesichts dessen was ich dort
jetzt tut auch des Kriegs der
Kriegsereignisse innerhalb der außerhalb
Russlands schnellstmöglich zu verlassen
teilen sie seine Sorge
ich kann sie gut verstehen ich werde
niemals jemandem vorschreiben ob
nicht oder wann aber das diese Art von
Umstürzen eigentlich immer und gerade im
russischen sprachigen Raum schon immer
mit antisemitischen Wellen einhergingen
ist Tradition und den Juden des Landes
sehr wohl bewusst und ich denke gerade
wenn Russland den Krieg verliert und das
ist ja das Ziel hier dann wird das fast
zwangsläufig mit einem regenwechsel in
Russland einhergehen nicht unbedingt mit
einem guten aber ähm
russland hat diese
faschistische Bewegung
die immer irgendein Blitzableiter
braucht und eine eines der Merkmal ist
immer ein Feind im Inneren und das sind
sehr stark Quere Menschen aber die Juden
sind einfach so eine tradierte
Zielgruppe dafür
teilen
ich begrüße dr Irina scherbakova bin
sehr froh sie ist Historikerin und
Germanistin dass sie heute Abend bei uns
sind
und ich finde wir dürfen alle stolz sein
dass dr Schäfer hier ist sehen sie ist
die Mitgründerin von Memorial der
ältesten russischen
Menschenrechtsorganisation die den
Friedensnobelpreis verliehen bekommen
hat das heißt in diesem Zusammenhang ist
Dr scherbakova auch Trägerin des
Friedensnobelpreises herzlichen
Glückwunsch bin froh dass Sie hier sind
stolz auf Euch
sie lebt derzeit im deutschen Exil sie
hat Russland verlassen sie ist
Gastprofessoren in Lehrte an der
Universität in Jena moskau ist ihre
Heimat sie hat sie verlassen obwohl sie
das nie wollte sie lebt im Exil in
Deutschland der ist auch eine ganz für
mich ungewohnte Formulierung im Exil in
Deutschland ich bin froh dass Sie hier
sind dass Sie bei uns sind dass ich hier
sicher sind
was für sie zu gefährlich in Russland
ich habe nicht deshalb Russland
verlassen und eigentlich unsere
Organisation Memorial wurde ja am
Vorabend des Krieges liquidiert
und
es waren ja schon natürlich die
Säuberungen in Anbetracht des Krieges
wir haben das noch nicht so wahrgenommen
und ich würde Russland auch danach nicht
verlassen wenn der Krieg nicht gekommen
wäre also dann es ist dann die
Überlegung und das ist nicht die Gefahr
dass es würde ich sagen Zorn
Verzweiflung und ein Ohnmacht Gefühl und
jeder ein Teil unserer Organisation
versucht dort weiter zu arbeiten es sind
Menschenrechtler die dort sind die
sammeln nach wie vor Informationen und
über Menschenrechtsverletzungen über
Widerstand der hört nicht auf obwohl
natürlich in nicht in der
wie wir uns vorgestellt haben an dem Tag
wo der Krieg ausgebrochen ist das war so
eine Katastrophe dass man ein Gefühl
hatte jetzt während jetzt sehr viele
Menschen auf der Straße sein aber das
war leider es gab Menschen natürlich in
Großstädten aber das war nicht so wie
wir es uns vorgestellt haben und
natürlich
verlässt man das Land
mit einem Gefühl also wenn man 30 Jahre
wie unsere Organisation für
Menschenrechte Aufarbeitung Aufklärung
auftrat und sehen müsste wie das alles
also zerbrochen wird wie dieser Krieg
jetzt alles vernichtet noch zusätzlich
dann hat man dann ist nicht das geht
nicht um die Gefahr
es geht um etwas es geht um etwas
anderes und es geht um etwas
existenzielles für dich ja sagen aber
das bedeutet nicht dass man
aufhören muss also etwas zu sagen und
ich brauche ich glaube es ist unsere
Aufgabe nach wie vor und auch die
Menschen auch in Russland zu
unterstützen also die dort Widerstand
leisten aber ich will ja noch etwas
sagen vielleicht noch einen Satz dazu
es war eine Frage die an uns gestellt
worden ist warum Frieden Nobelpreis was
habt ihr für den Frieden gemacht er war
ja 30 Jahre in dem Land etwas gemacht
und
eigentlich verloren
und wenn wir sagen ja wir haben ja
wirklich versucht seit mindestens sein
Puten macht Eintritt zu sagen also es
ist eine ganz gefährliche Entwicklung
aber viel früher mit dem
tschetschenischen Krieg schon das mit
gröbsten Menschenrechtsverletzungen
verbunden war und man wollte es wirklich
nicht wahrnehmen und das war ja keiner
bestraft ja dafür für diese
Menschenrechte Verletzungen niemand von
von der Militär also das gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung Verbrechen begangen
worden ist niemand und das hat sich
angebaut angestaut und
ja jetzt sind wir dort wo wir sind aber
ich würde ja noch vielleicht
einen Satz sagen dieser
dieses Jahr das wahrscheinlich das
Schlimmste und schrecklichste Jahr in
meinem auch langem Leben war Herr
Schäuble hat 56 da war ich sehr klein
erwähnt
68 war eine Katastrophe weil man die
letzten Hoffnungen waren weg
aber
andersrum 89 war das Jahr das mit so
vielen Hoffnungen verbunden war also für
uns und es war wirklich für Russland
eine Chance und umso schrecklicher ist
das dass diese Chance nicht wahrgenommen
worden ist also Schanze für Demokratie
und für die Freiheit und
jetzt dieses Jahr war wirklich das
schrecklichste für die meisten Menschen
um mich um mich herum die ich kenne in
Deutschland in Russland aber es auch
seine Lehren glaube ich für uns alle
aber ich will noch begrüßen natürlich
ganz herzlich Michael schiefkind es
Schriftsteller romanshöhe ein brillante
es ist wie nicht nur ich finde es in
Moskau geboren hat Deutschland studiert
dort gearbeitet
lebt inzwischen mit der Familie in der
Schweiz also auch nicht mehr in Russland
und er hat aber in Russland das muss ich
doch mal sagen weil es nur einen
einzigen Autor gibt der das geschafft
hat nämlich drei die drei wichtigsten
Literatur Auszeichnungen hintereinander
weg zu gewinnen das war sehr besonderes
Glückwunsch dazu
seine Romane die sind alle gerne
empfehle sind inzwischen in über 30
Sprachen übersetzt das letzte Buch ist
auch sozusagen im
Übersetzungsvorgang hat den Titel Krieg
und Frieden geschrieben vor dem Krieg
zusammen oder Frieden genau ich bin
weiter als Deutsch andere Etage
ja Krieg oder Frieden eigentlich Frieden
oder
so war es genau ja mit dem ins wissen
leider verstorbenen Fritz Pleitgen
und ich erinnere mich noch als wir dies
Buch gemeinsam vorgestellt aber das
Fritz Pleitgen noch noch dabei war aber
Micha ich will noch eine andere
Erinnerung bei dir gerne Abfragen weil
deshalb bin ich auch per Du weil wir uns
aus dieser Zeit nämlich kennen es ist
der 19 August 1991 Moskau lubianca also
die KGB zentrale und da hat mein Chef
gertruge damaliger hd-reporter ich war
der zweite Reporter da äh ihn interviewt
und erinnerst du dich noch was du gesagt
hast mich ja an diesem putschwarzen
zusammengebrochen dieser Nacht also das
war nicht am Neuss das war auch schon am
20 oder am 21
mein Sohn ist jetzt Michael 3 Jahre alt
und ich bin glücklich dass er in einem
freien in einem demokratischen Russland
aufwachsen wird
ja jetzt ist er in Hamburg er ist
aufgewachsen nach Hamburg also mein
ganzes Leben lang habe ich einen festen
Boden unter den Füßen gefüllt das war
die russische Kultur
also jetzt in diesem Jahr ist der Boden
weg
ich habe in diesem Jahr plötzlich
verstanden
was können Sie mir mal ehrlich mit
seinem schwarzen Quadratmeilen
der Künstler hatte das Vorgefühl was
weiterkommt und dann kam der erste
Weltkrieg dann kam der schrecklichste
blutigste Bürgerkrieg und dann kam der
Gulasch also jetzt ist das Russland
dieses schwarze Quadrat
du hast gerade an die und so habe ich
dich auch in Erinnerung in jeden Tag
weil wir da alle euphorisch waren auch
wieder Reporter ist der Putsch
zusammenbrach weil ja niemand mehr auch
als Reporter da nicht mehr aus dieser
Union berichten was was dann kommt die
Euphorie war groß und ich erinnere mich
eine Katrin bei uns im Studio war sehr
bewegt als sie das war wie du mit deinem
Sohn diese große Hoffnung auf Freiheit
aus es war wirklich Wahnsinn wann
hattest du zum ersten Mal die Ahnung das
kann auch ganz anders kommen also sehr
Erfüllung als der tschechische der erste
technische Krieg angefangen hat dann war
es für mich schon alles klar
ja also in Russland gab es keine der
stalinisierung nach dem Zerfall der
säuber es gab keine Nürnberger Prozesse
gegen die kommunistische Partei
und die Entstehung der neuen Diktatur
war nur die Frage nun die derzeit und
einer Diktatur braucht von der Natur aus
Feinde und einen Krieg jetzt werden sind
wir in diesem Krieg ja können sie sich
die Situation 45 in Deutschland
vorstellen die Alliierten würden ja die
Gestapo für die Entstehen des neuen
Deutschlands ja
verantwortlich machen gerade das
passiert in Russland wer war für die
Demokratisierung in Russland
verantwortlich die kargabel Leute wie
Puten welche welches demokratische
Russland konnte man da noch erwarten
also wir bekommen das was wir bekommen
also du hast sehr viel früher als viele
andere da schon vorgesehen was da kommt
das darf ich aber ganz herzlich begrüßen
die zdf-korrespondentin Katrin Eugendorf
die den längsten und sicherlich
schwierigsten Weg er hatte hierhin zu
kommen sie konnten nämlich aus der Front
aus
der Ukraine direkt hier nach Weimar
herzlich willkommen
ich glaube wir haben alle deine
jedenfalls sehr viele deiner Sendung ich
vielleicht sogar alle
deiner Sendungen gesehen deiner Berichte
deiner Reportagen auch im Jahrestag
deine frontreportagen dann als du mit
Frau slomker auf dem Dach in kiewstein
ist als ihr das heute journal von dort
ausgemacht hattet und und alle Arbeit
die ganzen Wochen davor auch schon
gemacht hat dass da kann ich nur sagen
weil ich ein bisschen auch mit Krisen
Berichterstattung zu tun hatte dass du
das physisch durchgestanden hast war
alleine schon enorm erleistung und das
hast Du journalistisch
geliefert das überall die Wochen und
Monate ist allerdings auch kein Zufall
denn du hast praktisch alle wichtigen
Medienpreise zu Recht im letzten Jahr
bekommen
Friedrichsbau ist denke ihre Preise bist
du Journalistin des Jahres gewählt
worden aber wenn jemand diese Preise
verdient hat dann bist du die diese
schwierige Arbeit macht vielen Dank
dafür
und Kathrin du bist natürlich für uns
jetzt auch jemand die das am dichtesten
erlebt hat was sich dort abspielt du
kommst aus Kiew du kommst von der von
der Front wie ist die Stimmung dort was
was würdest Du beschreiben was ist im
Moment dort das was die Leute was Sie
bedenken was sie ängstigt was sie hoffen
also ich würde sagen in der ganzen Zeit
und ich habe diesen Krieg ja von Anfang
an begleitet haben die Menschen dort
verschiedene Etappen durchgemacht und
die Etappe in der wir uns jetzt befinden
ist
ein Land am Tiefpunkt
weil die Ukraine haben natürlich jetzt
verstanden
dass die Schrecken dieses Krieges nicht
zu Ende sind sondern weitergehen dass
sie in ein weiteres Jahr des Krieges
gehen und ich glaube fast jeder Ukrainer
wenn nicht sogar jeder hat
Opfer gebracht kennt Menschen die
gestorben sind
hat Familie verloren und ist von diesem
Drama betroffen und dass das jetzt
weitergehen soll ohne dass eine
Perspektive erkennbar ist ist natürlich
eine sehr sehr bittere Erkenntnis auf
der anderen Seite was man positiv sagen
kann
sehen die Ukraine natürlich nach einem
Jahr Krieg wie sehr der Westen nach wie
vor an ihrer Seite steht also der Besuch
von
US-Präsident beiden in Kiew ich war
selber auch da das ist von den Ukrainern
schon wirklich gefeiert worden als etwas
was Ihnen Rückhalt vermittelt hat ich
meine es sind natürlich die großen
Bilder und es ist ja die Ukraine
verstehen das natürlich auch
entsprechend zu vermarkten aber
nichtsdestotrotz das war so ein ein
positives Zeichen und auch das was wir
jetzt erlebt haben dass er nun endlich
mal Waffen geliefert werden über die so
lange debattiert wurde das sind positive
Zeichen nichtsdestotrotz auch
militärisch muss man sagen ist die
Ukraine mittlerweile am Tiefpunkt
angelangt also das müssen wir nicht
beschönigen was wir im Moment im Land
erleben sind an einigen Fronten die
bittersten und schlimmsten Kämpfe die
man bisher erlebt hat es gibt keine
offiziellen Zahlen über Opfer aber was
man sich als Reporter dort zusammen
reimen kann wenn man einfach mal
hinguckt kann man das nicht hoch genug
einschätzen was da an Tribut gezahlt
wird auch an an toten Soldaten also ich
gebe mal ein Beispiel ich war in
kraketen gibt es einen riesen Friedhof
da werden jeden Tag mehrere Soldaten die
einfach aus der Front am Osten kommen
aus dem Osten kommen begraben das sind
Bilder die jetzt nicht immer jedem
präsent sind aber die zeigen natürlich
das sind die Toten und von den
verletzten reden wir noch gar nicht
und was ich selber
an bei den paar besuchen die ich gemacht
habe an an der Front
erlebt habe ist ein Krieg also
den kann man sich nicht bitter genug
vorstellen dort sind teilweise Soldaten
die haben den russischen Angreifern
nichts entgegenzusetzen außer ihre
Kalaschnikow und werden da manchmal auch
einfach überrannt
und diese Realität
ja vor der steht die Ukraine jetzt
und ist die Frage ja wie lange wird das
noch dauern es ist denkbar dass sagte
weil ich immer jemand auch eine Dame die
es wissen muss dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg verliert
ja ich glaube wir müssen definieren was
heißt gewinnen und verlieren
so wie ich die Ukraine und das ist
natürlich immer nur eine Momentaufnahme
erlebe werden sie nicht
zurückweichen also die Entschlossenheit
der breiten Masse der Bevölkerung diesen
Krieg weiter zu führen auch mit allen
Opfern
ist sehr groß und jetzt ist Präsident
selensky jemand der das natürlich auch
sehr schön zu verkaufen weiß er hat ja
gesagt
an die Russen gerichtet wir sterben
lieber als dass wir unter eurer
Besatzung Leben mit Vergewaltigung und
Mord Entführung von Kindern
aber das stimmt das ist das Gefühl
glaube ich was viele oder die große
Masse der Ukraine haben sie wollen nicht
unter russische Herrschaft leben weil
sie wissen einfach was das bedeutet
du hast von einem solchen Ort berichtet
nämlich von Butcher und
das war eine sozusagen wieder eroberte
Stadt kannst du uns schildern was für
ein Eindruck du von dieser Stadt hat das
als ankams
also das war ja die erste Stadt die im
Prinzip wo wir erlebt haben was passiert
ist wo wir sehen konnten was haben
russische Söldner russische Soldaten
dort gemacht und für mich
war das mit eines der schlimmsten
Erlebnisse die ich in meiner Laufbahn
als Journalistin erlebt habe und ich
habe schon über einige Kriege und Krisen
berichtet zu sehen
dass man Zivilisten einfach mitten auf
der Straße hinrichtet
Menschen in irgendwelche Gruben schmeißt
eine komplette zerstörte Innenstadt
einfach mutwillig zerstört zurücklässt
das Soldaten und Söldner durch die
Häuser gezogen sind und dort randaliert
und wandern Sie sich wie beim Dahlen
aufgeführt haben Frauen vor den Augen
ihrer Familie vergewaltigt haben das
alles ist in Butcher klar geworden dass
das passiert und das hat mir gezeigt
welcher Natur dieser Krieg ist das ist
nämlich ein Krieg da geht es um viel
viel mehr als um die Eroberung von
Territorium das ist ein
Vernichtungskrieg gegen ein Volk es ist
ein Vernichtungskrieg gegen das
ukrainische Volk
und das ist glaube ich jedem klar der
Butscher gesehen hat und deswegen glaube
ich wird Butcher als das auch in die
Geschichte eingehen wir haben solche
Situationen immer wieder in dem Krieg
erlebt auch teilweise noch drastischer
entgegenden die länger noch von Russen
besetzt waren aber Butcher war eben der
erste Ort
wie erklären wir du hast es ja schon im
Grunde gerade getan aber ich frage es
trotzdem noch mal diese diese wirkliche
ich habe deine Berichte von dort gesehen
auch was in deinem Buch darüber
geschrieben hast wo ich mehrfach einfach
das Buch zur Seite legen musste um Zeit
zu gewinnen und mich dann wieder neu zu
widmen und du hast es alle selbst erlebt
aber diese
unvorstellbare Grausamkeit die man mit
gesundem hören gar nicht sich
fantasieren kann wie erklären wir uns
dass das ist genau dazu kommt zu dieser
diese übermorgenden
[Musik]
Kriegs
Rausch und wie man das nennen mag oder
ist es Politik
das ist sehr sehr schwierig das jetzt in
ein paar Worten zusammenzufassen das
liegt natürlich einerseits in der Natur
des russischen Militärs ja ich meine das
ist ein Militär das an sich auch schon
gegen die eigenen Soldaten auf brutalste
und im humanste Art und Weise vorgeht
das sind Soldaten die werden in einen
Krieg geschickt von ihren eigenen
Vorgesetzten misshandelt das ist eine
Armee die funktioniert nicht nach den
Prinzipien ja sagen wir einer modernen
Armee
und dann wird es auch belohnt das
Verhalten wird belohnt also man hat ja
ich man hat das in einigen Orten gesehen
da sind die Soldaten einfach losgelassen
worden in die Städte die haben Geschäfte
geplündert die haben sich in Häusern
eingerichtet haben dort
Wodka andere
Alkoholiker getrunken das ist kommt ja
in einer normalen Armee nicht in der
Form vor und was hat man hinterher
gesehen die schlimmsten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen die
grausamsten Verhaltensweisen wurden ja
vom Kreml noch honoriert
das heißt es ist gewünscht es ist auf
der einen Seite eine Armee die an sich
die ein Spiegelbild der kompletten
Verrohung der russischen Gesellschaft
ist und auf der anderen Seite wird
dieses Verhalten eben auch belohnt
hat sich ja im Grunde genau damit
beschäftigt nämlich die Grausamkeiten in
der sowjetischen Zeit
hast du eine Erklärung es gab vorher
schon solche Grausamkeit in der
Sowjetunion das ist richtig aber das ist
sozusagen überborn jetzt wieder
aktiviert werden kann wie erklären
ich glaube das war das war so also Putin
hat erstens war wirklich eine
Vorgeschichte übrigens es ist vor einer
Woche ein Bericht von unseren
Menschenrechtler aus Memorial
zusammengefasst und veröffentlicht
worden wo man also das nachvollzieht
also welche Verbrechen seit also in den
sogenannten kleinen kriegen also
angefangen mit Tschetschenien dann war
auch die syrische Geschichte wo man die
Städte komplett ausgebombt hat also das
dass wir sozusagen das wird dass wir
gezeigt aber ich würde ja sagen noch es
gibt eine Erklärung also die dann auch
noch zusätzlich ist Putin hat geglaubt
und das wollte ich ja am Ende so zu
meiner ersten Runde Putin hat geglaubt
er schafft das in einer Woche und nicht
nur er allein sehr viele Menschen auch
im Westen also in Russland haben
geglaubt also es wird in eine Ukraine
kann sich nicht gegen gegen Russland
verteidigen und es war ein Plan wie wir
wissen was mit silentski passiert was
also eigentlich und man und es war
absolut verboten unerwartet dass er so
einen Widerstand bekommen hat und dann
wurde also
diese Armee noch irgendwie also oder die
Menschen dort die wurden ja noch
zusätzlich noch aggressiver in dieser
also in dieser Geschichte dass Sie dass
das nicht erreicht haben was erreicht
wurde werden sollte und natürlich stimmt
ja alles das ist selbst schlecht
behandelt werden und das ist
unglaubliche also Visiten herrschen dass
niemand bestraft worden ist durch den
tschetschenischen Krieg aber das ist
noch etwas
mehr würde ich sagen das ist die Gewalt
die dann auch in der russischen
Gesellschaft selbst sich mehr und mehr
durchgesetzt hat und sie haben ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen wie in all diesen
Jahren gegen die Demonstranten
vorgegangen worden ist wie man
zusammengeschlagen hat
ältere Frauen also fast Kinder
verschleppt zusammengeschlagen und
wissen Sie was auch in den schlimmsten
ist Zeiten war es doch nicht so dass ihm
dass die Menschen die Studenten wurden
schlecht behandelt natürlich
künstlich ernährt es gab dann
zwangsmäßige Psychiatrie Verordnungen
und so aber es wurde nicht gefoltert
seid stalinszeiten jetzt wissen und das
wissen die Menschen in Russland denn
wenn man verhaftet wird wenn man auf
einer Kundgebung geschnappt wird wenn
man wenn man in einen Strafkolonie kommt
es kann es wird massiv Folter angewendet
also das ist das passiert auch in
Belarus nicht nur nicht nur in Russland
und das ist das breitet sich aus
sozusagen das hat im gewissen Sinne dann
keine Grenzen als und das ist eine von
den Erklärungen und etwas vielleicht
noch ein Satz dazu
also es ist ja auch massive Anwendung
von sexueller Gewalt das hat als also so
massiv ist es auch niemals niemals
gewesen
naja was man dann bevor ich dann zu
hören bekomme aber wir sind glaube ich
ein genau dem Punkt wo man sich fragt
ist da bei den Ukrainern sozusagen wenn
da eine ein alter Alptraum wieder wacht
denn es gibt ja eine durchaus blutige
Geschichte unter anderem der sogenannte
Holo doma das heißt die künstliche
Erzeugung einer Hungersnot wo unter
Stahl von Stadien angeordnet und brutal
durchgesetzt wo man sagt drei vielleicht
fünf drei bis fünf Millionen Menschen
einfach verhungert sind Marina weiß wann
ist das was jetzt passiert zu sein die
Wiedererweckung dieses alten Traumas von
dort droht uns nur solches
natürlich die Ukraine hatte dahingehend
mehrere Traumata ich würde nicht
unbedingt sagen dass es nur der Hodor
ist die Ukraine hat ja
beides erlebt
Teile der Ukraine haben relativ junge
europäische Vergangenheit gerade der
Westen
man hatte eine Kosaken Tradition die bei
einer basisdemokratische Elemente hatte
und die Ukraine hat natürlich die
Sowjetunion erlebt und ähm sie hat so
sehr also die Menschen dort haben ja
dieselbe Kultur gelebt für die
russischen Menschen und in dieser
Erfahrung hat man dieses Gefühl
verinnerlicht ich bin als Mensch
individuell Staub meine Mutter hat
gesagt nachdem sie nach Deutschland
gekommen ist hat sie fünf Jahre
gebraucht und zu lernen was Selbstwert
ist
und ich glaube die Ukraine hat
dahingehend eine ganz ähnliche Lernkurve
durchgemacht wie meine Mutter wir alle
haben auch noch das Trauma der 90er
Jahre das auch die Russen teilen also
die diese Zeit von völligem Chaos und
Hunger und Korruption und Menschen mit
mit Waffen auf offener Straße die sich
einfach alles unter die sich alles
Krallen was geht was jetzt plötzlich
privatisiert ist und diese
erstkapitalanläufe machen
Putins versprechen war ja immer mit mir
gibt es Ordnung in diesem Chaos und ohne
mich kommen die 90er wieder
und ich glaube russland hat sich dann
dafür entschieden ja wir wollen lieber
diese Ordnung wir wollen lieber dahin in
einen unterdrückerisches Regime zurück
und die Ukraine hat sich nicht erst seit
dem Mai dann es gab auch vorbereiten die
Orangene Revolution entschieden wir
wollen eigentlich ein westliches Land
werden wir wollen einen demokratisches
Land sein wir wollen frei von Korruption
leben
und ich habe schon auf dem Maidan
gesehen dass diese Menschen nicht
zurückweichen werden hinter dieser
Vorstellung es ist nicht nur eine Angst
es ist auch etwas das mächtiger ist als
Angst es ist eine Vision darüber wie
dieses Land sein könnte wie man leben
will es ist etwas dass es in Deutschland
schon lange nicht mehr gibt eine Art
positive Zukunftshoffnung die
so lange geherrscht hat und die man
jetzt verteidigt
hat vor etwa zwei Jahren einen Aufsatz
geschrieben der zunächst erstmal in der
Fachwelt oder den servisten und so und
den interessierten Fachleuten
wahrgenommen worden ist er schrieb er
über die Beziehung zwischen den
Ukrainern und den Russen und in diesem
Aufsatz kann man nachlesen kann ich nur
empfehlen wäre verstehen will wie dieser
Mensch bezogen auf Ukraine denkt diesen
Aufsatz über die Einheit von Russland
Ukrainern den gibt es in deutschen
Übersetzung einfach zu lesen um zu
verstehen was der Mensch denkt und da
sprach er in diesem Aufsatz schon lange
bevor der Krieg begann der Ukraine das
Existenzrecht als eigener Staat nicht
teil von Russland sein ab
nun hat auch Russland das Budapester
Memorandum unterschrieben und einiges
andere mehr die Ukraine hat
manche erinnern es vielleicht nicht mehr
so richtig aber immer in die Atomwaffen
zurückgegeben und hat dafür dann
territoriale Integrität zugestanden
bekommen zu gewinnen bekommen jedenfalls
versichert bekommen die waren sich
sicher dass das so kommt
für Putin ist das offensichtlich alles
Makulatur und wie erklären wir uns das
also soweit
verstehe
ich glaube ich der Schlüssel
dass er gesagt hat der Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion war die größte Katastrophe
des 20 Jahrhunderts
und deswegen glaube ich
fürchte ich eben
das ist nicht allein um die Ukraine geht
und dass er in Wahrheit ich meine
Ukraine
war vorher
Moldawien ist schon gar nicht mehr
bezweifelt nicht und dann ist eigentlich
schon die Frage wo ist next
wer kommt danach
und
deswegen
glaube ich wenn das Prinzip nicht mehr
gilt
meine wenn man so einen Krieg anfängt
dann wird er so
das macht der Krieger aus den Menschen
und du kriegst ja auch normale
diese Art von Krieg zu führen kriegst
die Soldaten nur mit brutalen zwang dazu
das war immer so den Armee die Angst vor
Dissertation
muss größer sein als die Angst zu fallen
im Krieg es gibt schon der Krieg macht
aus den furchtbaren Dingen aber der
eigentliche Punkt ist
wenn wir mit wenn das Prinzip
nicht mehr gilt was eben im kalten
Kriege geholfen hat
jedenfalls nicht um das Risiko eines
Krieges
Grenzen zu verschieben
dann kommt es darauf und deswegen
es ist ein Krieg auch
im Ergebnis gegen uns ist gar nicht nur
unser Mitleid gefordert das sagte ja
übrigens selbst der Einsicht gefordert
dass
die Ukraine eigentlich auch für uns
kämpfen
und natürlich verstehe ich wir haben ja
jetzt auch am Sonntag gerade die große
Demonstration gehabt und
darf das alles auch nicht kleinreden
muss auch die Menschen irgendwie
versuchen zu verstehen aber es ändert
nichts daran nach meiner über
bitteren Überzeugung ist er muss
er oder
diejenigen die in Russland vielleicht
die Führung übernehmen oder übernehmen
können muss einsehen sie werden damit
kein Erfolg haben und deswegen
bin ich so froh
dass wir ein amerikanischen Präsidenten
haben zurzeit von dem wir gar nicht
geklappt hätten dass der in einer
solchen Weise auch mit Augenmaß aber
doch auch mit unheimlicher Kraft das
notwendig der einzige der neben
natürlich China
aber der einzige der putineinheit bieten
kann sind die Amerikaner die Europäer
sind es nicht mit allem Respekt vor der
Kampfkraft unserer unserer Leos Leopards
und dergleichen mehr das allein ist es
natürlich müssen wir das tun aber das
eigentliche was wir in Deutschland so
bitter es ist
begreifen müssen
er wird ja auch wenn er gewinnen sollte
nicht aufhören
und den folgenden
ist es auch unsere Sache
die da auf dem Spiel steht und das macht
unsere macht das alles so furchtbar
schwierig und schmerzlich
was ich sagen halte ich für zutreffen
das hat auch wirklich gedauert bis
sozusagen diese diese Wahrnehmung diese
Erkenntnis und die Schlussfolgerung die
sie ziehen sich in breiteren Kreisen
sozusagen irgendwie auch durchsetzt also
diese Realität am Ende und nicht das
Wunsch denken wie es ist aber die eine
der entscheidenden Fragen ist natürlich
immer eines gelingt ihm nicht dieses
Ziel zu erreichen was immer genau sein
Ziel sein mag
wenn wir jetzt sagte vor ein paar Tagen
bis an die polnische Grenze zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel man kann noch viel weiter
gehen was würde denn tun sprich diese
latente auch mit weder wiederum der
ehemalige Präsident
atomare Drohung er sagt ich glaube ich
gestern heute es wird ein nukleares
Inferno oder ähnliches dann eintreten
und das das ängstigt die Menschen ja
zurecht es ist ja ne gefährliche Sache
wie gehen Sie damit um
ich meine der hat ja das Tabu schon
verletzt dass er überhaupt sich war ja
ein Tabu auch nur mit dem Einsatz von
Atomwaffen zu drohen
damit machte er schon politischen
Gebrauch von Atomwaffen
da hilft nur die Lehre aus dem Kalten
Krieg
man muss klar machen
dass man
dem sich nicht
und dass man natürlich versuchte zu
verhindern und dann wird man vielleicht
auch wieder
man hat ja im Kalten Krieg auch gelernt
in den 60er und 70er Jahren nachdem man
die Wende kam ja irgendwann in der
Kubakrise nicht wo ja damals
die beiden Hauptverantwortlichen und
Christoph und Kennedy ein hohes Maß an
staatsministereife
und wir ja damals öffentlich gar nicht
so erfahren haben dass natürlich die
Amerikaner die Gegenleistung gebracht
haben ihre Raketen aus sehr
Sowjetunion mit Nachbarn Teil
Natürlichkeit
zurückzuziehen dazu muss man wieder
kommen aber solange wir
den Eindruck erwecken wir schrecken vor
der Drohung zurück
solange werden wir das nicht schaffen
deswegen müssen wir alles tun das
Bündnis
mit den vereinigten Staates Metall
deswegen müssen die Europäer mehr machen
denn dass die Amerikaner sagen hey ihr
Europäer tut mal ein bisschen mehr es
ist ja eine andere Frage aber das ist
die die wirklich bittere Frage und dass
wir
also unsere Generation ich bin ja
zwei Krieg geboren aber in der
Nachkriegszeit aufgewachsen und die und
all die Jüngeren
ältere hat sich gibt's ja nicht mehr
ernst zu nehmen viel die
wir haben das
wir können uns das gar nicht mehr
vorstellen und jetzt müssen wir lernen
dass dieses Prinzip
das auch in Zeiten des Kalten Kriegs
dann irgendwie gegolten hat so in Frage
gestellt wird
und darüber müssen wir müssen wir dann
offen diskutieren in Deutschland müssen
auch den Menschen erklären
tut mir leid
es hilft uns nichts
diplomatie ist wichtig wir müssen alles
tun
dass wir den Einfluss der der Dritten
Welt also der
wir hatten ja früher immer schon die
brickstarten also Brasilien Russland
Indien China Südafrika das war so bei
den in den in den Finanzminister und
geht 20 Zeiten immer eine große
Gruppierung wir müssen hoffen dass
die Amerikanerin die Chinesen
hinreichend kooperieren
um eben eine solche Eskalation zufrieden
und gemeinsam können sie glaube ich auch
genügend Druck auf Russland
ich nehme aus ihrer Antwort mit man muss
dem Druck widerstehen und in dem Fall
nicht nachgeben ich glaube man darf
unterstellen ein Politiker ich weiß gar
nicht ob sie Harbeck war oder eine
andere sagte wer bei Sinn und sagt
wahrscheinlich jeder fünfte Mensch
Verstand ist will natürlich dass dieser
Krieg endet und das Frieden kommt die
Frage ist aber eben wie und die
entscheidende Antwort haben sie mir für
mich jedenfalls gerade gegeben indem man
diesen dieser Drohung dieser Atom nicht
nach katrin ist das denn diese diese
diese Drohung mit Atomen Schlag in der
Ukraine ist das Thema
ängstigt dass die Menschen was denken
die darüber glauben die der tut das am
Ende
es kommt ganz darauf redet also das ist
natürlich ein Thema aber das ist nicht
als Thema so präsent wie wie das hier in
z.B in Deutschland diskutiert wird also
dieses trostszenario was Putin mit mit
einem atomaren taktischen atomaren
Schlag aufbaut das richtet sich ganz
klar in den Westen weil er natürlich um
unsere Ängste weiß
viel viel größer sehe ich im Moment die
Gefahr dass es zum Beispiel zu einer
nuklearen Katastrophe rund um das
Kernkraftwerk saparice geht das unter
russischer Besatzung ist und wo
katastrophale Zustände herrschen das
kommt in den Medien gar nicht so sehr
präsent vor aber da ist die Gefahr viel
größer das ist auch ein unbeabsichtigter
Unfall dort entsteht dass es den Russen
aus der aus der Kontrolle gerät weil da
ist das größte Kernkraftwerk Europas
unter Besatzung in einer in einer
Kriegssituation also das ist ja im
Prinzip ein eigentlich unvorstellbares
Szenario ähm ja was was viel
bedrohlicher wird wenn man sich dann mit
sagen wir mal mit Regierungsvertretern
auch den Verantwortlichen in Militär
Kreisen unterhält die sehen die Option
ja einer einer Eskalation in in Richtung
chemischer biologischer und atomarer
Waffen schon als realistisch an also
damit kalkul wenn man in der Ukraine
durchaus dass das passieren kann der
Vorbereitungen auch schon getroffen um
dem irgendwie
Journalisten nicht aber das nehme ich
mal an ja das ist das natürlich werden
Sie darauf vorbereitet sein also davon
gehe ich aus aber das sind natürlich
alles Dinge so wie die Zahl der Toten
genauso wie die Zahl wie die Frage von
militärtaktik das ist wird natürlich als
gut gehütetes Geheimnis nicht an uns
Journalisten weiter getragen aber ich
denke wenn man wenn man einfach
interpretiert wenn man diese Frage
stellt dann höre ich immer wieder raus
ja man hält das für möglich das Russland
bereit ist in diesem Krieg auch weiter
zu eskalieren allerdings wenn man sich
dann mal anguckt was würde das dann was
würde das denn in diesem Krieg am
Szenario ändern kann Russland natürlich
mit dem Einsatz von taktischen
Atomwaffen
an der militärischen Situation nichts
ändern ja also dass das würde ja keine
große Verschiebung bedeuten würde aber
das Risiko nach sich tragen dass
Russland ist mit den wenigen Verbündeten
die es ja noch hat China Indien
möglicherweise auch verscherzt denn
sowohl China als auch Indien hat ja
unmissverständlich klar gemacht das ist
für sie eine rote Linie ist und das
sehen die Russen natürlich dass sie ohne
China und Indien dann ziemlich alleine
stehen
nicht wir sind per Du und ich kann es
nicht mehr verheimlichen auch vor dem
Saale nicht ich wollte eigentlich eher
so passieren es geht irgendwie nicht ich
kenne uns einfach zu lange und dafür bin
ich auch dankbar traust du ihm dazu
Putin dass er in einer atomarenschlag
ausführt
also vor allem möchte ich die Frage
stellen wen verdanken wir diesen Krieg
Putin oder westlichen Politiker die die
ganz all diese Jahre gesagt Politik ja
gegen betrieben haben
klar die westlichen Politiker verstehen
nicht in Russland die sind auch die
Experten angewiesen
und diese Experten die immer ja gesagt
und geschrieben haben man muss die
Brücken zu Putin bauen ja diese Puten
versteht diese Russland verstehen ja wir
müssen jetzt diesen Experten danken dass
wir jetzt in diese Situation sind
2018 das war schon alles klar dieser
Krieg ja dauerte schon vier Jahre schon
tausend und Tausende von Toten
Fußballweltmeisterschaft
ich versuchte in der Schweiz und bei
Gott zu organisieren ich wäre in der
Presse im Fernsehen ja hier der Krieg
hier Moral hier Milliarden und
Milliarden von Fußball ja Gewinner wer
hört auf Schriftsteller alle Nationen
kann man nach Russland und vor kurzem
Fußball zu spielen
für ihn war das absolut klare
Zusage hat das als Zusage zu seinem
Krieg war genommen und die Tür zu 24
Februar 22 war offen damals man muss ja
Russland zuerst verstehen wie Russland
funktioniert ja
die wichtigsten Fragen die russischen
Fragen aus dem 19 Literatur die ewigen
russischen fragen wäre es schuld was tun
die bewegten nur die Leserschaft
150 Millionen bauen haben nicht lesen
können für die war die wichtigste
russische Frage ist der Zahl falsch oder
echt und die Frage bleibt als richtig
russische Frage für die russische
Bevölkerung auch bis jetzt man kann
diese Frage beantworten nur mit dem Sieg
wenn der Zar sieht dann ist er echt so
meint die russische Bevölkerung und nur
so kann man das erklären dass stalen
Millionen und aber Millionen vernichtet
haben
aber durch seinen Sieg ist der der echte
Zahn bis jetzt in den Augen
Gorbatschow hat den Afghanistan Krieg
verloren hat den Kalten Krieg gegen den
Westen verloren klar ist ein falscher
Zahl bis jetzt verpönt und gehasst
das ist die einzige Legitimation das hat
jelsen verstanden ja es war Chaos es war
ein Archie er ist kein echter Zahl er
muss deinen Sieg da wollte er genauso
wie putiniert seinen schnellen Sieg
gegen Tschetschenien macht die generell
haben den versprochen in zwei Tagen
nehmen wir Nein ja er kann den Krieg
verloren
gehasst das hat guten absolut verstanden
er hat den ersten
Krieg gewonnen dann hat ihm die
Legitimation die eine Aktion der Creme
gebracht ja er ist der rechte Zeit die
russische Bevölkerung hat Creme
naschkriminasch ja die Krim ist unser
nur so funktioniert Russland und dann
deshalb dieser Krieg ja der braucht
wieder
einen kriechen er braucht wollte auch
einen sicheren Sieg wie in der Ukraine
jemanden die generell haben in drei
Tagen Kiefern zu nehmen versprochen der
hat sich verkalkuliert weil jeder
Diktator irgendwann die Beziehung zur
Realität verliert er bekommt nur die
Information die er haben will
hätte er gewusst wer es endet Brücken
wir
hätte Hitler im Bund april 1945 hätte er
ja nach Tom Wave
gedrückt ja sicher wünschen wir das auch
in der letzten Minute drücken wollen
wenn er schon eine Pistole im Genick hat
ja aber weil er kein echter Zahl ist
dann werden seine Befehle nicht verfolgt
nicht erfüllt lesen Sie die
patriotischen
Oppositionellen Telegramm Kanäle die
schreien vom Hochverrat wo ist rasiert
es gibt keinen Sinn der Zahl ist nicht
echt der Zar ist falsch
also er wird sicher versuchen aber es
wird nicht glauben dass sie die Antwort
auf die Frage das würde aber heißen er
geht wirklich bis zu diesem Punkt danke
Ja wir dürfen gerne reagieren unbedingt
ich Stimme hören Schäuble zu ich glaube
das ist also das ist ein Trumpf und sein
Trumpf ist Spekulation Betrug und Angst
einjagen vor allem dem Westen es ist
gegen nicht gegen die eigene Bevölkerung
also diese ganzen atomwaffengeschichte
Bedrohung sondern gegen Westen gerichtet
und ich stimme Ihnen absolut zu also das
ist eine Erpressung und das muss man als
Erpressung wahrnehmen und
die einzige Möglichkeit also erstens
also dieser Erpressung nicht nachgeben
also nicht sagen dass man sich irgendwie
mit dem also
versöhnt oder irgend so ein Frieden also
anfängt nein gar nicht also man muss
eigentlich alles tun damit Puten diesen
Krieg diesen Krieg verliert es ist
schwierig es hat sich gezeigt wie
schwierig das ist aber es hat sich auch
gezeigt was man für einen Weg gegangen
ist in diesem Jahr in erster Woche
nachdem über die Wahl ging es darum um
Helmen und Google sichere Westen zu
liefern an die Ukraine jetzt also jetzt
hat sich jetzt sehen wir wie sich das
geändert hat in diesem Jahr es hat aber
leider gezeigt dass Westen nicht
vorbereitet war das sozusagen die
Erfahrung und die Lehre ist eine sehr
bittere für uns alle weil also das haben
wir auch nicht so erwartet dass NATO
nicht vorbereitet ist das ist alles
irgendwie nicht so funktioniert wie wir
es vorgestellt haben
dass die Struktur nicht den Tag sind
nicht stark genug sind und das UNO und
das sind die bitterste Erfahrung nach 45
das UNO nicht funktioniert dass die
ganze Putin hat die ganze Weltordnung
auf den Kopf gestellt es geht ja nicht
nur natürlich um diesen Knopf sondern um
das was wir eigentlich wirklich in
diesen
schon fast 80 Jahren ja gehofft haben
und deshalb glaube ich tun sich die
Menschen alle überall so schwer in
Europa und auch überall weil es ist es
ist ein Bruch mit der Welt mit der
friedensweltordnung und das muss man
leider das muss man leider soll man
sagen darauf muss man sich besinnen also
das ist eine ganz entscheidende Frage
und deshalb betrifft es uns alle nicht
nur Russland nicht nur Ukraine sondern
uns alle meine weißband es ist es geht
um mehr als um die Ukraine aber es geht
im Augenblick vor allem um die Ukraine
kathrin hat ja geschildert wie viel
Widerstandskraft sie dort erlebt nach
wie vor auch in dieser
überaus schwierigen Lage wenn ich das
richtig verstehe glauben Sie dass die
Ukraine die ukrainische Bevölkerung ja
vor allem die die zum Teil ja sehr
jungen Soldaten in diesem wie soll ich
denn sagen in diesem Szenario das
aussieht wie im ersten Weltkriegen
diesen schutzgremer sind Katrin ja auch
berichtet sondern jemand anderen Stellen
auch sehen kann dass sie wirklich noch
diese Kraft haben das durchzustehen
weiß ich nicht ich weiß dass dass sie es
versuchen werden ich weiß dass sie nicht
aufgeben werden aber ob sie es können
sie müssen sich vorstellen die
ukrainische Wirtschaft ist um 40 Prozent
geschrumpft können Sie sich vorstellen
was in Deutschland los wäre wenn die
Wirtschaft um 40% schrumpft mein Onkel
bekommt seit letztem Februar kein Gehalt
mehr sagen Sie mir wovon soll er seine
Familie ernähren so ganz stumpfe Fragen
und ich fange nicht an von den Jungs in
den Gräben ich fange nicht an von dem
was sie mit sich tragen das Haus
gegenüber meinem Haus gibt es nicht mehr
das ist weg und
ich
ehrlich gesagt
frustriert es mich so sehr in
Deutschland zu leben und zu sprechen
weil die einen in Deutschland sagen das
ist Gott sei Dank die Minderheit die
Ukraine sollen sich doch gar nicht
wehren die sollen einfach aufhören sich
zu wehren und von Russland besetzt sein
und dann ist Frieden und die anderen
sagen
nein die Ukraine muss sich verteidigen
und dieser Krieg wird wahrscheinlich
noch viele viele Jahre dauern
und ich finde beides nicht akzeptabel
beides nicht weil es nicht hätte so weit
kommen müssen putin hatte Zeit
nachzurüsten putin hatte Zeit für seine
Mobilisierung und er hatte Zeit diese
neue mobilisierten Soldaten jetzt
auszubilden er hatte Zeit zu reagieren
nach seinem Fehler weil der Westen ihm
diese Zeit gelassen hat weil beiden in
rückversichert hat vor der Invasion dass
die NATO nichts tun wird wenn er in die
Ukraine marschiert weil beiden gesagt
hat wir sind bereit aus der Ukraine ein
neues ein zweites Afghanistan zu machen
weil Olaf Scholz bis heute nicht die
Worte die Ukraine muss siegen in den
Mund nimmt
und mich stellt das vor Fragen und ich
kann diese Fragen nicht beantworten ich
will nicht irgendwas zu Recht fabulieren
es kann sein dass es interne Logiken
waren und Chaos und institutionelle
unvorbereitetheit warum wir alle
Kollektiv so langsam reagiert haben
gerade mit sehr notwendigen
Waffenlieferungen es kann aber auch sein
dass das Kalkül dahinter ist dass
Russland verliert und die Ukraine
gewinnt verschiedene Ziele sind Russland
soll verlieren ja aber Russland verliert
am nachhaltigsten wenn es möglichst
stark ausblutet an der Ukraine das heißt
dass dieser Krieg möglichst lange dauern
soll und Putin möglichst viele Leute
rein schickt
ich weiß nicht ob das die Strategie ist
denn eine Strategie wurde in Deutschland
nicht kommuniziert wir haben von unserem
Bundeskanzler nicht gesagt bekommen das
und das ist die Strategie der Regierung
in Bezug auf die Ukraine das sind unsere
Ziele das ist wie wir sie verfolgen
wollen
deshalb weiß ich nicht ob das so ist ob
wir schneller mehr hätten liefern können
ob diese Verzögerungen absichtlich waren
oder oder Zufall aber für mich ist das
eine sehr bedeutsame Frage und sie ist
auch eine bedeutsame Frage insoweit wie
sehr ich mich mit Deutschland
identifizieren kann was ich meine
Verwandtschaft zu Hause erkläre
es ist sehr bitter
zwischendurch wenn Sie Fragen haben
Finke ist dabei die dann einzusammeln
und die bringen wir dann auch in diese
Runde ein
Herr Schäuble
sie sind einer der erfahrensten
Verhandler in der Politik das kann man
glaube ich
ganz nüchtern festhalten das hat auch
viel unter anderem mit der deutschen
Einheit zu tun und vielem andere mehr
was tun jetzt es wird ja irgendwann ein
Moment kommen an dem entweder einer der
beiden in die Knie geht oder die
Kriegslage sich entsprechend verändert
ich will es gar nicht beschreiben welche
das sein müsste dass man an sowas wie
Verhandlungen denken muss nicht einfach
naiv und irgendeiner wie soll ich sagen
an irgendeinem Mikrofon sagen lieber
Frieden und verhandeln ja alles gut das
Gegenüber muss es wollen den Eindruck
hat man bis jetzt von Putin nicht in
keiner seiner entscheidenden reden gab
es irgendeine Art von anzeigen könnte
man mit dem überhaupt verhandeln mit
jemand der praktisch alle europäischen
staatsch ist buchstäblich angelogen hat
sie vorgeführt im Kreml an diesem
irlandisch
seltsames Szenario so oder so
was denken Sie wenn Sie an so ein Wort
wie verhandeln Denken in dem
Zusammenhang
naja
zunächst einmal
ist es richtig dass man jedenfalls alle
die die nicht unmittelbar beteiligt sind
sich darüber zumindest öffentliche
überhaupt nicht den Kopf zerbrechen
sollten das ist ja zunächst einmal eine
Frage an die Ukraine selbst
und was wir tun können
sollten wir ich sage entscheidend
ist aus meiner Sicht aber dazu bin ich
eben zu sehr
in der in der atlantischen Sicherheit
aufgewachsen im Kalten Krieg
entscheidend ist was die Amerikaner
machen und ich finde nach wie vor
dass der amerikanische Präsident
es aus meiner Beobachtung
klug macht der hat ja auch den Satz
gesagt wir überlegen krampfhaft welchen
Ausweg wir Putin bieten könnten
Christoph haben das damals bei der
Kubakrise ich habe so eine lebhafte
Erinnerung der bei der Kubakrise haben
wir damals auch täglich die Nachrichten
verfolgt und wie weit ist jetzt noch wie
weit ist die sie ist die sowjetische
Marine noch von Kuba entfernt und und
und weil wir damals natürlich mit der
Möglichkeit
und dass wir uns das wirklich vorstellen
können was bedeutet der eine atomare als
das atomaren Weltuntergangs ein Stück
weit auseinandergesetzt haben also man
muss dann schon ein Ausweg lassen das
geht aber nicht alles was wir jetzt tun
ist eigentlich
bei Putin zu über die Überzeugung zu
nähren die halten das nicht durch die
Ukraine nicht und der Westen nicht
in Amerika gibt es dafür viele Anzeige
nicht in einem in Amerika habe ich
gelesen
sagen die jedenfalls die ein Teil der
Republikaner der besser nach ohaia
gegangen wo es so ein schlimmes Unglück
mit einem Chemie Transport gegeben hat
als nach Kiew zu fahren naja gut Amerika
war auch schon mal weltpolitisch ein
bisschen größer als mit diesen und die
Europäer sind auch müde und wenn Sie bei
uns Ihnen Debatten anschauen dann ist es
auch so also ja gut vielleicht muss man
auch der Bundeswehr noch ein bisschen
den Haushalt fahren unsere
Haushaltsverhandlungen was in den
Zeitungen lesen
und ich sag da gar nicht dass die
Opposition sich ich bin ein bisschen
jetzt bin ich ein bisschen
also ich kann mir da Zurückhaltung
aber ich meine wenn Sie die Debatten in
Deutschland verfolgen
dann können Sie ihn in
Kremmen sondern auf die zu der einzig
kommt lange halten die das nicht durch
und die in Europa auch nicht entscheiden
Frankreich noch viel weniger in
Frankreich interessiert der Ukraine
kriegt die Menschen noch weniger als in
Deutschland
am ehesten ist es noch bei unseren
osteuropäischen Nachbarn die bald ist
die Staaten die Polen
natürlich ja natürlich die bayerischen
Staaten ohne dies die waren Teil der
Sowjetunion sagt man darf noch mal ein
qualitativer ein kleiner qualitativer
Unterschied nicht und
deswegen
war es auch so wichtig
dass der amerikanische Präsidentin
gesagt hat wir werden wir stehen zu
Artikel 5 des nato-vertrags
glauben Sie wirklich dass wir in
Deutschland
bei einer Meinungsumfrage wenn man sagen
würde sind die Deutschen dafür
dass wir notfalls was in Artikel 15
Jahre Vertrag steht wissen Sie nicht und
wir betrachten einen Angriff auf
einlassen Angriff auf uns und sind dann
noch haben wir nicht mehr die Debatte
und für Kriegspartei werden oder so wir
sind dann glauben Sie wirklich dass wir
dafür in Deutschland eine Mehrheit
ich glaube da haben wir noch ein
bisschen Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
dass dieser Angriff gegen uns geht und
deswegen fürchte ich wir müssen jetzt
nicht öffentlich über Verhandlungen
reden
sondern Putin überzeugen nein und
deswegen würde ich mehr und schneller
und effizientere Waffen liefern und
insofern haben wir auch ein
entschuldigen sie
entschuldigen Sie
dürfen die Frage gerne abgeben wo ist
denn Herr Finke jemand wollte die Frage
einsammeln da hinten wenn Sie das nach
hinten tun ja
aber er hat zu Recht ja unbedingt soll
er ja auch Micha du hast auch darüber
geschrieben
wird am Ende dieser
Episode möglicherweise zu zerfallen
warum
also wir haben
also wir verstehen alle warum die
Ukraine kämpfen weil sie für ihre
Freiheit kämpfen ja das ist
wahrscheinlich wir haben noch überhaupt
nicht darüber gesprochen warum die
meisten Russen diesen guten schon Krieg
gegen die Ukraine unterstützen ja warum
als also vor einem Jahr
niemand im Westen konnte
verstehen wieso gehen die
russenmassenhaft auch nicht auf die
Straßen um gegen den Krieg zu
protestieren das waren nur einzelne
Helden und Helden die jetzt im Gefängnis
sitzen und ich habe es mir
erklärt ja das ist die Angst
das ist die Überlebensstrategie der
Generationen die Macht kann sowieso
machen was sie will ich kann überleben
nur wenn ich schweige
die berühmten Zeile also Puschkins Paris
der letzte Zeile nach rot bismotzt wird
das Volk schweigt das ist die
Überlebensstrategie in Russland pur
aber dann kam Herbst die mobil machen
und hunderttausende
gingen
gehörig in den Tod und die Ukrainer zu
töten
das war schon keine Angst das ist schon
was anderes es ist viel tiefer viel
schrecklicher was war das
also
man muss verstehen in Russland gibt das
quasi zwei Nationen die russische
sprechen die sich als Russen bezeichnen
die das gleiche Territorium teilen aber
das sind mit mentalpsychologisch ganz
verschiedene Menschen ich liebe im 21
Jahrhundert
ich trage die Verantwortung für die
Entscheidung was ist gut was ist böse
und wenn ich sehe dass mein Volk mein
Land was Böses tut dann bin ich gegen
mein Volk denn ich gegen mein Land
aber die meisten Russland die Leben
mental noch in der Vergangenheit die
identifizieren sich mit dem Stamm
und unser Stamm ist immer gut hat immer
Recht andere Stimme sind Feinde wollen
uns vernichten
und ich über ich übernehme überhaupt
keine Ahnung antwortung die
Verantwortung trennt der
Zahl
und nur der Zar kann uns ja retten wir
sind da so eine heilige Insel im Ozean
der Feinde
und alle Diktatoren und alle Zahlen
haben es verstanden wie man dieses
wunderschöne Gefühl der Liebe zu Heimat
missbraucht
mein Vater ja sein Vater wurde starken
Gulasch also mein Großvater aber als der
Krieg begann ging mein Vater ja
freiwillig an die Front um seine Heimat
zu verteidigen
er verstand nicht dass er nicht seine
Heimat verteilt dich ja sondern Gulasch
er meinte er bringt die Freiheit ja von
Faschismus nach Europa gebracht
und jetzt passiert das gleiche ja Puten
Propaganda
benutzt diesen Mythos des großen Vater
schon Vaterländischen Krieges die
Faschisten aus der Ukraine aus der Natur
haben
wollen uns vernichten wir müssen unsere
Heimat verteidigen
wie kann man diesen Leuten erklären dass
sie jetzt nicht die ihre Heimat von
Faschismus verteidigen das ist selber
Faschisten sind
dass sie die Vertrag Verantwortung
übernehmen müssen das ist so die die
zivilisationslücke die kann man diese
Lücke überbrücken
glaube ich auch noch
es ist viel komplizierter als das weil
er und ich glaube also ich brauche in
Thüringen das nicht zu erklären was es
bedeutet für die Menschen in einer
Diktatur zu leben und was es mit den
Menschen auch macht aber das ist wie
gesagt jetzt die Situation ist
kompliziert der ersten seit dem Beginn
des Krieges ist hat fast eine Million
Russen Russland verlassen und das war
anders als in den 90er Jahren sind die
Menschen weggegangen sie eigentlich
gegen diesen Krieg waren und seit 1917
gab es keine so große Immigration und
das war ja schon ein Zeichen also wenn
man natürlich sind das alles es ist sehr
schwer auszurechnen weil ähm
soziologische Umfragen sind sowieso eine
komplizierte Geschichte und jetzt auch
unter solchen Zensur Bedingungen wo
schon das Wort Krieg nicht mal
gebrauchen kann darf ja es wird der
Krieg wird nicht als Krieg genannt wie
sie sie wissen nenne sondern Operation
Konto und und die Menschen sind auf die
Straße gegangen trotz allem also obwohl
es wirklich also jeder der ging also
wusste also was er riskiert und es sind
tausende seit dem Beginn des Beginn des
bestraft worden ins Gefängnis gesteckt
worden mit hohen Strahl also mit hohen
lagerstraßen versehen also nein es gibt
diesen Widerstand nur es ist wirklich
ihn nicht in der Mehrzahl aber ich
glaube so und wenn man sogar sagt ja die
Menschen sind von der Mobilisierung
dieser hunderttausende sind von der
Mobilisierung geflüchtet sie sind nicht
wirklich also gut ins Gegner also wenn
sie auch das nicht so wie wenn diese das
letztendlich wirklich mit dieser
Mobilisierung begriffen haben wohin die
Reise geht dann ist es trotzdem gut dass
sie nicht an der ukrainischen Front sind
das muss man ja das muss man ja auch so
sehen und diese Menschen muss man in
diese also diese bezüglich auch
unterstützen dass sie also nicht in
diesem Krieg gegangen sind aus welchen
aus welchen immer aus welchen Gründen
und
ja
michael hat schon recht es ist natürlich
Jahrzehnte der Unfreiheit Jahrzehnte der
Anpassung Angst ja das spielt eine Rolle
aber das ist nicht doch nicht das ganze
Land es ist es nicht und ich glaube
meine Hoffnung die Menschen versuchen ja
das wirklich also sich zu verstecken
also diejenigen die also geblieben sind
und trotzdem also meine also meine
Hoffnung ist dass ähm
die sich das anders sich entwickelt wir
Puten es sich vorstellt weil was Putin
verkündet hat wenn Sie das wahrgenommen
haben in seinen letzten reden er spricht
er nicht schon vom Sieg
niemals hat er gesagt also wir werden in
diesem Krieg Siegen und es wird eine
schöne Zukunft also für alle wären also
mit diesem Signal er sagt etwas ganz
anderes er sagt eigentlich und das ist
dafür kündet sagt er wir werden das ist
unsere Realität jetzt normalisiert
diesen Zustand also wir werden jetzt in
diesem Krieg leben wir müssen uns damit
alle abfinden dass wir also in diesem
Krieg sind also das ist natürlich eine
Vision wie beim Euro 84 das man den
ewigen Krieg ist aber meine Hoffnung ist
also so groß auch Russland ist
bin ich nicht so bisschen mystisch wie
Marina das sagt ich meine Hoffnung ist
dass ähm
er auch keine Möglichkeit haben wird
also diesen dieses diesen Zustand so in
die Länge zu ziehen dass die Menschen
sich also immer mehr und mehr und mehr
damit abfinden umgekehrt also wenigstens
meine Hoffnung ist dass es in einer
umgekehrte Rechnung Richtung gehen wird
wann es möglich sein wird dass die
Menschen sich wirklich auflehnen und auf
die Straße gehen also wirklich
massenweise das wissen wir nicht so wie
unsere Zukunft eigentlich in
Wirklichkeit sind das zum Beispiel
Spekulationen aber ich glaube was uns
allen jetzt also was uns bleibt ist
alles zu machen damit seine Szenario
nicht verwirklicht wird eine Frage noch
bevor wir dann
bevor wir dann zu ihren Fragen kommen
Katrin was wir noch nicht berührt haben
was aber glaube ich eine richtig große
Rolle spielt auch nach meiner
bescheidene Beobachtung ist die Rolle
der Medien wir haben beide zur gleichen
Zeit in Moskau und Russland gearbeitet
da war das so in dieser Form in den 90er
Jahren jedenfalls noch nicht der Fall
oder überhaupt nicht der Fall das ist
jetzt komplett anders
das ist kann man das als bösartige
Propaganda bezeichnen wenn man mit
nüchternen Blick drauf schaut
die Rolle der Medien der Masse also
insbesondere Fernsehens das russischen
Pferden
ja also das ist mehr als Propaganda
glaube ich also
das ist
ich möchte jetzt nicht historische
Vergleiche berühren aber
wollte den totalen Krieg das ist das was
ich in den russischen Staat sehen sehe
das ist ein schwören der Bevölkerung auf
den totalen Krieg
und zwar rund um die Uhr
und grenzenlos dieser Krieg richtet sich
nicht nur gegen die Ukraine sondern
dieser Krieg richtet sich gegen den
Westen insgesamt also ich meine im
russischen Staatsfernsehen wird von
topmoderatoren darüber spekuliert wie
man Berlin einnimmt
das ist etwas was vielleicht den
deutschen Publikum hier nicht so präsent
ist aber das ist die Realität
dessen was das was wir was was wir in
russischen Medien erleben und es gibt ja
es gibt keine freien Medien mehr in
Russland ich es hat ja
lange noch immer ein paar Inseln gegeben
wo sich Menschen informieren konnten
aber mittlerweile wird das ja zunehmend
schwierig also man muss sich ja
mittlerweile über eine vpn-leitung
einwählen um überhaupt Zugang zu anderen
Medien zu haben und die Medien selbst
die die unabhängig sind und mittlerweile
eigentlich fast alle aus dem Ex oder
alle aus dem Exil berichten wissen ja
auch sehr wenig also wenn wir uns jetzt
wirklich über das informieren wollen was
in Russland passiert
gibt es viele alternative Informationen
aber wer weiß denn was im innersten
Kreis der macht wirklich passiert
Sie sie als Russen wir erschließt es
sich nicht ja ich habe das deshalb auch
erwähnt weil du hast in 31 ich glaube
viele in der deutschen Bevölkerung auch
der der engagierten Diskutanten dieser
und jener Meinung und ist auch gut dass
man unterschiedliche Meinungen hat um
das mal ganz klar zu machen
ist sozusagen dieser mediale Komplex ein
Faktor des Verstehens warum ein Volk
relativ einhellig in diese Richtung
läuft es jedenfalls ein Faktor wir beide
kennen ja zum Teil noch Kollegen aus der
90er Jahren unter anderem der Chef äh
das medialen Konzern
das war ein liberaler meiner damaligen
Wahrnehmung jedenfalls Kollege der im
überhin auch in der Ukraine meine
Talkshow hatte im Fernsehen
und und auch die westliche Lebensart
nicht nur gekannt hat sondern auch gerne
gelebt hat also da hat sich doch eine
Menge verändert aber jetzt kommen wir zu
ihren Fragen
ich bitte darum ja ich habe in meiner in
der Stadt in der wir leben meine Frau
nicht wenn man nicht in Berlin sind in
Offenburg eine relativ große
Gemeinschaft von Russlanddeutschen die
Anfang der 90er gekommen sind
insbesondere bei den jüngeren die also
hier aufgewachsen sind die den ganzen
Tag Raster today sehen
ist die Unterstützung für die russische
Position im Ukraine kriegt völlig
frappierend das zeigt selbst in
Offenburg kannst du allein mit Wasser
today die Leute so beeinflussen der
irrsinnige Position vertreten wie sollte
sie Russland dann anders sein
so lieber Finke sie haben die Fragen
eingesammelt vielleicht können Sie auch
gleich dazu sagen ein wenig die Frage
richtet falls das da eben gesagt worden
ist ja vielen Dank Thomas Roth wir
hatten Sie meine Damen und Herren ja
anfangs gebeten wenn Sie eine Frage
haben die zu notieren wir haben einige
bekommen
zusammengekommen und ich möchte davon
einige exemplarisch Vorlesen die erste
Frage geht dann das gesamte Podium
Weimarer Deutschen Nationaltheater also
wenige Meter entfernt hängt ein großes
Transparent auf dem steht Diplomatie
Frieden jetzt die Frage an das Podium
wie stehen Sie zu dieser Forderung
gesagt natürlich
Diplomatie immer aber im Augenblick ist
meine Bewertung der Situation so dass
wir zunächst einmal Putin oder die
Führung Russlands davon überzeugen
müssen
das ist das Kalkül die Ukraine und die
westliche Unterstützung würden schneller
müde als die Russen darauf spekulierter
ja
nicht aufgeht das wir uns auch der
Erpressung nicht beugen Irina
das ist für mich immer die Frage mit wem
Diplomatie
wer wird also mit wem soll man ja
verhandeln
mit wem
und und hat macron nicht genug
verhandelt drei Stunden lang telefoniert
was hat das was hat das was gebracht
wird das was bringen es wird nur das
bringen das gute Zeit gewinnt und nichts
anderes mehr also er kann in diesem
Sinne es wird kein Frieden geben es ist
eine sehr milde gesagt es ist die Idee
ja wirklich jeden Tag vorbei und wundere
mich also wie naiv Mann sein kann also
aber naiv ist in dieser Situation eine
sehr gefährliche Geschichte
jeder brennen wer will nicht Frieden und
wer will nicht dass man miteinander
redet nur man braucht jemand ich habe
jetzt vernommen von die mit dem Sprecher
des präsenzitiert gesehen dass er sagt
nee der chinesische chinesische
Vorschlag ist nicht das was Frieden
bringen wird dieses zwölfpunkte-papier
dass er in der politischen Debatte war
in den letzten Monaten ja was dann
ich glaube wir müssen einfach
wir sehen ja dass diese Debatte jetzt
wieder in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
geführt wird und ich muss sagen wenn ich
erlebe dass
so etwas wie ein
friedensmanifest hier in die
Öffentlichkeit getragen wird
das den Ausdruck Frieden hier in dem
Zusammenhang zu benutzen ist eine
Irreführung es kann keinen Frieden geben
zu den Bedingungen zu den Russland das
Bild bei Frieden hieße dann einfach nur
Abwesenheit von was vielleicht nicht mal
Abwesenheit von Gewalt weil wenn der
Frieden den russland will eintritt dann
ist die Ukraine komplett besetztes Land
dann wird es auf dem kompletten
ukrainischen Territorium das geben was
wir in den besetzten Gebieten erleben
nämlich Vergewaltigung
von Frauen Mord Entführung von Kindern
das als Frieden zu bezeichnen halte ich
für wirklich eine massive Irreführung
Marina weißband
Marina weiß bei den Münster ich denke
der Fehler auf dem Plakat ist ein ganz
einfacher Frieden und jetzt ist ein
Widerspruch in dieser Situation es gibt
genau einen der Frieden jetzt schaffen
kann das ist Putin mit dieser Forderung
darf und soll man sich sehr sehr gern
und Putin wenden wahrscheinlich wird er
einem nicht zuhören wenn jetzt
Waffenstillstand dann heißt das noch
Jahre und Jahre von Krieg denn wir haben
es 2014 schon ausprobiert wir hatten
mindestens zwei
Putins Ziel ist ja nicht die Ukraine zu
erobern Putins ziel ist die Demokratie
zu zerstören Putins Ziel ist zu zeigen
das ist entweder so ist wie er will oder
gar nicht und
wenn wir ihm nicht zeigen dass es nicht
geht mit seinen Methoden dann wird er
weitermachen und natürlich führt er auch
Krieg gegen den Westen bei uns taucht
das immer nur so auf als äh hier ist
eine Desinformationskampagne und hier
ist ein Hacker Angriff auf eine
kritische Infrastruktur aber in
Wirklichkeit erleben wir natürlich
Attacken auf unsere Demokratie von
staatlichen Akteuren und nicht
staatlichen Akteuren
Frieden und jetzt ist in dieser
Situation ein Widerspruch und ich will
Frieden und deshalb nicht jetzt sondern
dann wenn der Aggressor zurückgeschlagen
ist
[Applaus]
ja die nächste Frage richtet dann
Zuhörer an Frau Eigendorf freikendorf ab
wann wussten sie dass Russland die
Ukraine überfallen wird sie hätten dies
in einer kürzlichen Reportage erklärt
dass sie nicht überrascht gewesen sein
also ich wusste dass am 24 Februar des
letzten Jahres um 5 Uhr morgens ich habe
damit nicht gerechnet ich hatte muss
ehrlich gestehen ich habe nicht bis zum
Schluss trotz eigentlich
klarer Informationen auf der Amerikaner
die da immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
haben nicht damit gerechnet dass Putin
das wirklich tun wird also zu dem
konkreten zu der konkreten Frage die
Ukraine komplett zu überfallen ich
glaube die die Frage richtete sich viel
mehr
an einen eine Debatte die wir letztens
mit meiner Kollegin im Ausland Journal
hatten ob ich
Putin das zugetraut hätte dass er das
macht und ja das hätte ich Putin schon
seit langem zugetraut weil
extremer Nationalismus
und die Errichtung eines totalitären
Regimes beschränken sich nie auf Gewalt
nach innen diese Gewalt wird immer
irgendwann nach außen getragen und die
Gefahr dass das passiert ist natürlich
in einer globalen so eng
zusammengewachsenen Welt wie wir sie
jetzt haben noch viel größer und das
haben wir schon sehr früh gesehen das
haben wir
in den Kriegen die Putin davor geführt
hat gesehen
und der Ukraine Krieg ist ja nicht der
erste und wir erleben das jetzt
eigentlich zu Ende geführt in einem
Krieg der wirklich flächendeckend die
Vernichtung ja eines eines eines eines
gesamten Landes zum Ziel hat
vielen Fragen darf die letzten die
vorletzte Frage geht wieder das Podium
wenn Russland den Krieg verliert welche
Perspektive sehen Sie für Russland und
Europa
ja da gehen wir vielleicht nicht das
ganze Podium durch aber Micha würde
gerne mit dir anfangen welche
Perspektive siehst du
also es ist für mich absolut klar der
Krieg wird dauern bis Putin im Creme ist
wie er geht wir wissen es nicht das
Ergebnis klar
dann beginnt der Machtkampf in Russland
und für die für die Leute die an diesem
Tag beteiligt sind werden ja jetzt keine
Rolle spielen wenn die kriegen gehört ja
das heißt für die Ukraine wird mit dem
Abgang von Putin der Krieg zu Ende sein
die Ukraine wird nämlich an so eine
riesenmauer an der Grenze 91 bauen und
schauen was da in Russland passiert und
der Russland wird nicht gutes Passieren
der Prozess des Zerfalls das Imperiums
wird weitergehen
die Russische Föderation ist hier jetzt
hochschwanger mit neu starten so wie es
die Sowjetunion war
ob diese neustarten demokratische
demokratisch entpuppen ja da habe ich
meinen Zweifel obwohl ich wie irenischer
Barcode selbstverständlich auch hoffe
dass irgendwann alles gut sein wird aber
ich glaube es ist etwas kompliziert
dann eine Demokratie braucht die
kritische Masse der Bürger und das hat
Putin absolut gut verstanden ja er lernt
lernt aus den Fehlern der vorherigen
Diktatur die Sowjetunion war ein
Gefängnis man konnte nicht flüchten die
heutige Diktatur hat keine Grenzen alle
die uns zufrieden mit uns sehen hat noch
mit Videos damals als Präsident gesagt
bitte es gibt keine Grenzen weg also
Millionen und aber Millionen
der Bürger des eventuellen
demokratischen Russland sind mit ihren
Familien in den letzten Jahren Weg ja
die bauen die Demokratie die Zukunft in
Israel in Amerika in Deutschland aber
nicht in Russland weil sie dort für sich
keine Zukunft und für ihre Kinder keine
Zukunft sehen und diese Politik geht
weiter bei der mobilenmachung haben die
die Grenzen extra offen gemacht so ein
Millionen junge Männer die unzufrieden
mit der Politik sind waren Weg für die
Diktatur ist das besser ja sonst hätten
diese junge Männer die Waffen bekommen
ja also das ist sehr gut für die
Diktatur sehr schlecht für die Zukunft
Russlands wer wird dann die Demokratie
war ja und klares kommt zur Anarchie zum
Chaos und so entsteht die neue Diktatur
die Diktatur kommt nicht mit dem
Diktator der sagt also Leute jetzt bin
ich schon die Diktatur kommt mit dem
Verlangen nach der Ordnung die Russen in
den 90er Jahren und die deutschen 20er
Jahren haben das schon alles erlebt ja
und dann nach diesem Verlangen nach der
starken Hand konnte sich die starke Hand
und der Westen wird diesen neuen Putins
die Hand drücken weil die im versprechen
werden die Kontrolle über die atomaren
Waffen zu halten ja und die russische
Geschichte wird ihren Schwanz wir wieder
Anbeißen zwischen einem Schriftsteller
und doch einem Historik
[Gelächter]
ich hoffe selbstverständlich auch
ich hoffe dass alles andere das das
ist ein pflichtoptimismus
ein russischer Autor der bekannten
Deutschland hat mir gesagt nicht du
änderst immer schlecht man muss anders
ändern weißt du die Leute wollen was
optimistisches du musst so sagen könnte
mir gesagt Russland ist ein Land der
Wunder es passieren immer Wunder und wir
hoffen dass ein Wunder wieder passiert
diese Hoffnung teilen wir alle mit dir
ich hoffe dass sie tragen kann Irina sie
wollten uns noch ein bisschen ergänzen
weil es ist vielleicht etwas
komplizierbar in dieser Richtung ich
glaube das ist das sind alles
Spekulationen und es gibt natürlich auch
Beispiele in der Geschichte die etwas
ganz anderes und zeigen also in einer in
einer Woche haben wir 70 Jahre seit dem
Stall ins Tod und damals war auch eine
fast eine Panik in der Gesellschaft weil
man geglaubt hat es wird viel schlimmer
wenn er stirbt es bedeutet dass eine
Katastrophe Verlosung und mit nichten in
zwei Wochen haben sozusagen seine
schlimmsten Schergen also wie Beria also
mit der Tauwetter angefangen also das
ist also sozusagen diese Spirale die
kann nicht ewig zusammen also sozusagen
also zusammengeballt werden dass das
geht nicht also und ähm
über Zerfall Russland zu spekulieren ist
auch glaube ich noch nicht an der Zeit
weil ich sehe auch keine besondere
Zentren also die dann sich also
herausbilden können um wirklich also
diesen also es kann wie gesagt es ist
alles möglich aber
ich glaube
also die Geschichte kennt auch ganz
andere ganz andere Beispiele
in 10 Jahren gut vielleicht in fünf
lieber
letzte Frage okay auch angesichts der
fortgeschrittenen Zeit die letzte Frage
das war der Herr hier links gerade die
ist sehr lang das hat nur ein kleiner
Teil davon an dr Schäuble am besten ich
lese mal vor Gewalt gegen Gewalt führt
nur zu mehr Verhärtungen mehr
Grausamkeiten welche nicht militärischen
Druck welche positiven falt
Verhandlungsangebote kann ich speziell
Deutschland machen
ich glaube Deutschland kann speziell
keine
Verhandlungsangebote machen
was wir tun sollten ist unseren Beitrag
leisten zu einer möglichst
geschlossenen
und möglichst
für Putin und oder Russland
überzeugenden Antwort des Westens zu
leisten aber wir selber können keine
speziellen Angebote machen mein was wir
Russland anbieten sollten wenn ich
gefragt würde als Westen wäre dass wir
uns als Westen bemühen müssten das wird
auch in Amerika nicht so ganz einfach
sein zu verstehen dass im 21 Jahrhundert
die Welt eine multipolare Ordnung
haben wird wir hatten ja die kurze Zeit
der
Illusion nach 1990 jedenfalls in Teilen
der Welt das jetzt nur noch eines
Supermarkt verblieben ist das hat in der
Weltgeschichte nie lange gehalten
ich kann mich noch an meinen wir waren
befreundet der war damals
Nato-Generalsekretär der frühere
Verteidigungsminister Manfred Wörner der
war in der Phase Nato-Generalsekretär
und der hat in den in der kurzen Zeit
die ihm noch geblieben ist der hat er
musste früh sterben hat er sich
unheimlich eingesetzt für ein neues
Verhältnis zwischen dem Westen
gar nicht nur der NATO und Russland also
die NATO Russland Partnerschaft und
ähnliches
aus welchen Gründen des alles am Ende
nicht gelungen ist darüber kann man
lange diskutieren da kann man
wahrscheinlich auch
vielerlei Fehler auch in der westlichen
Politik finden das nützt uns aber alles
heute nichts heute sind wir in der
Situation
das zweite Buch
massiv verletzt worden sind das eine ist
dass man mit gewaltgrenzen jedenfalls in
Europa nicht mehr verändern kann das war
das Prinzip der Nachkriegsordnung selbst
im Kalten Krieg und das andere ist dass
man mit dem Einsatz von
Massenvernichtungswaffen also ABC-Waffen
das ist ja richtig nicht nur die
nukleare die
bitte
lassen Sie uns die Sendung
freundlicherweise zu Ende bringen also
ich habe es nicht verstanden
was Sie gesagt haben ich glaube die
beiden Tabus sind verletzt und es
sollten möglichst schnell in eine Welt
zurückkehren und die beiden Prinzipien
akzeptiert werden und wir als Westen
zugleich akzeptieren müssen
das nicht alle
unsere Vorstellungen
von freiheitlich rechtsstaatlich und
Demokratie so teilen
wir kennen ja Fukuyama der geschrieben
hat vom Ende der Geschichte und wir
kennen Huntington der ein paar Jahre
später geschrieben hat toystore ich
nicht vom clash of cultures die große
Mehrheit der Weltbevölkerung ist nicht
von euren
westlichen Vorstellungen so
hundertprozentige
werden wir ein bisschen selber
selbstkritisch sind wir haben uns ja mit
unseren Ordnungsvorstellungen denken Sie
nur an die Jahrhunderte des
Kolonialisierung auch nicht mit Ruben
bekleckert das heißt wir könnten auch
von der eigenen Tür kehren aber die
beiden
und bis dahin lassen wir uns nicht
erpressen
eine letzte kleine Frage habe ich selbst
noch und sie geht an Marina weißband
nach Münster Marina wenn sie jetzt in
diese in dieser Minute in dieser Sekunde
gemeinsam mit uns an Kiew denken was
denken sie dann
ich denke dass wir die Pflicht haben
eine Hoffnung zu senden eine Hoffnung
nach Kiew einerseits und in die ganze
Ukraine das wir bei ihnen stehen und
zwar ehrlich und zwar aus der tiefen
Überzeugung heraus dass das nicht
staatskalkül ist dass das nicht
Geopolitik ist sondern dass wir eine
geteilte Welt der Menschlichkeit haben
dass wir ein geteilte Vorstellungen
darüber haben was menschliches Leben und
seine Unversehrtheit wert sind aus
dieser Vorstellung heraus
Menschen die diese Grundprinzipien
verachten klare Grenzen setzen und die
Hoffnung an uns selbst und gegenseitig
dass wir KEF nicht sehen als dieses
kleine Hundebaby das gerettet werden
muss sondern auch als eine Bewegung aus
der wird was lernen können in
Deutschland
nämlich für etwas zu kämpfen für etwas
zu kämpfen das nicht selbstverständlich
ist das einem niemals geschenkt wird
auch in der BRD nicht und dass wir hier
vor unserer Haustür kehren und mal
gucken wie steht es eigentlich hier mit
der Demokratie wie steht es eigentlich
bei uns mit den Menschenrechten mit
welcher Passion beteiligen wir uns
selbst an unserer Gesellschaft wo sind
wir Ihre Gestalterinnen und wo sehen wir
uns selbst als Opfer oder als Konsument
und nichts darüber hinaus ich glaube
jeder von uns kann so unendlich viel tun
in der eigenen Nachbarschaft jeder von
uns kann so unendlich viel tun für den
Mitmenschen und diese Hoffnung ist dann
Wirklichkeit dieses Gefühl ist das
was die Ukraine im Moment am Leben hält
und das was uns am Ende ein als Menschen
herzlichen Dank nach Münster herzlichen
Dank aber auch an dieses Podium dass Sie
den Weg hier nach Weimar gefunden haben
Katrin für dich was der längste
Anreiseweg er Schäuble wohnt auch nicht
direkt nebenan aber ein bisschen her
dann schon als
und mich da natürlich herzlichen Dank an
dich und dieses Wort Hoffnung nehme ich
einfach auch aus deinen Äußerungen mit
weil der immer vorgeworfen wird du bist
nicht optimistisch genug auf jeden Fall
bist du ein sehr guter Schriftsteller
und auch im Übrigen ein erfolgreicher
das ist auch was Gutes ob das mal stolz
sein kann Irina du hast für uns
Beobachter auch immer ein Stück Hoffnung
mitgegeben wenn wir dir in Moskau unter
anderem begegnet sind andere Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sich Informationen von
Memorial
erarbeiten bekommen was steckt dahinter
was spielt und lieber ganz herzlichen
Dank dass Sie uns durch diesen Abend
begleitet haben und ganz herzlichen Dank
an sie alle hier im Saal an die Weimarer
ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen und
vor allem das ist Kostbarste was wir
haben einen friedvollen Abend danke
schön
[Applaus]